been asking for like a family tree i'm  going to give it to you when my parents  were first married they adopted my  cousin mary parents are in their 20s  mary was like 15 when she lived with  them that's my oldest sister then my  parents started having kids there were  six of us discussed together when i was  in high school and when i was a freshman  in college we adopted brian he was in  high school next chaz joined our family  adopted him i think two or three years  ago and then when i was 22 i found out  that i had an older brother that my  parents had given up for adoption they  got pregnant when my mom was a teenager  and he's right there everyone and that's  my brother's girlfriend melissa she's  not family yet but she will be she  basically is